why do you think would dream what
place do we go to when we dream
and why are they useful not just um
not just the assimilation aspect but
just like all the crazy visuals that we
get with dreams is there something uh
you can speak to that's actually useful
like why we have such fun
experiences in that dream world
so
one of the
camps in the sleep field is that dreams
are meaningless
that they are an epi phenomenal
byproduct of this thing called rem sleep
from which dreams come from as a
physiological state
so
the analogy would be um let's think of a
light bulb
that the reason that you create the
apparatus of a light bulb is to produce
this thing called light in the same way
that we we've evolved to this thing
called rem sleep to serve whatever
functions rem sleep
but it turns out that when you create
light in that way you also produce
something called heat
it was never the reason that you
designed the light bulb it's just what
happens when you create light in that
way
and the belief so too was
that dreaming was essentially the heat
of the light bulb
that
rem sleep is critical but when you have
rem sleep with a complex brain like ours
you also produce this conscious epi
phenomenon called dreaming
i don't believe that for a second
i and from a simple perspective is that
i suspect that dreaming is more
metabolically costly as a conscious
experience than not dreaming so you
could still have rem sleep but
absent the conscious experience of
dreaming was probably less metabolically
costly and whenever mother nature burns
the energy unit called atp
which is the most valuable thing
um there's usually a reason for it so if
we're if it's more energetically
demanding
then i suspect that there is a function
to it and we've now since discovered
that dreams have a function the first as
we mentioned creativity the second is
that dreams provide a form of overnight
therapy dreaming is a form of emotional
first aid
and it's during dream sleep at night
that we take these difficult painful
experiences that we've had during the
day sometimes traumatic
and dream sleep acts almost like a
nocturnal soothing bomb and it sort of
just takes the sharp edges off those
difficult painful experiences
so that you come back the next day
and you feel better
about them
and so i think in that sense dreaming
it's not time that heals all wounds it's
time during dream sleep that provides
emotional convalescence
so dreaming is almost a form of you know
emotional windscreen wipers
um and i think
and by the way it's not just
that you dream
it's what you dream about
that also matters
so for example scientists have done
studies with learning and memory where
they
have people learn a virtual maze
and what they discovered was that
those people who then
dreamed but dreamed of the maze were the
only ones who when they woke up ended up
being better at navigating the maze
whereas those people who dreamed but
didn't dream about the maze itself they
were no better at navigating the maze so
it's not just that you it's not it's
sort of necessary but not sufficient
it's necessary that you dream but it's
not sufficient to produce the benefit
you have to be dreaming about certain
things itself and the same is true for
mental health what we've discovered is
that people who are going through a very
difficult experience a trauma for
example a very painful divorce
those people who are dreaming but
dreaming of that difficult event itself
they go on to gain resolution to their
clinical depression one year later
whereas people who were dreaming
just as much but not dreaming about the
trauma itself did not go on to gain as
much clinical resolution to their
depression
so
it's i think to me those are the lines
of evidence that tell me dreaming is not
epi phenomenal
and it's not just about the act of
dreaming it's about the content
of the dreams
not just the fact of a dream itself it's
first of all it's fascinating it makes a
lot of sense but then immediately takes
my mind to
from an engineering perspective how that
could be useful in for example ai
systems
of
[Music]
if you think about dreaming as a
important part about learning and
cognition and
filtering previous memories of what's
important integrating them
you know maybe you can correct me but i
see dreaming is a kind of simulation of
worlds
that are not constrained by physics
so like you you get a chance to take
some of your memories some of your
thoughts on your anxieties
and play with them
like construct virtual worlds and see
how it evolves
like to to play with those worlds in a
safe environment of your mind safe in
quotes because you could probably get
into a lot of trouble with
what the places your mind will go but
in um
this this this definitely is applied in
much cruder ways in artificial
intelligence so
one context in which this is applied is
uh
the process called uh self-play
which is uh reinforcement learning
where uh agents play against
it's itself or versions of itself and
it's all simulated of trying different
versions of themselves and playing
against each other to see
what ends up being a good
the ultimate goal is to learn
a function that represents what is good
and what is not good in terms of how you
should act like you create a set of
decision weights based on experience and
you constantly update those weights
based on ongoing learning but the the
experience is artificially created
versus actual
real data so that's it's a crude
approximation what dreams are which is
you're hallucinating a lot of things
to see which things are actually no i
think it's and it's been a theory that's
been put forward which is that dreaming
is a virtual reality test space that is
largely consequence-free
what an incredible gift to give a
conscious mind each and every night
now the the conscious mind the human
mind is very good at constructing dreams
that are nevertheless useful for you
like they're they're wild and crazy but
they're such that they are still
grounded in reality
to a degree where anything you learn in
dreams might be useful in reality this
is a very difficult thing to do
because it requires a lot of
intelligence that requires consciousness
uh this has been effectively recently
been used in self-supervised learning
for
computer vision
with the with the process of what's
called data augmentation is that's a
very crude
version of dreams which is you take data
and you mess with it
and learn you start to learn how a
picture of a cat
truly represents a cat by messing with
it in different ways
now the crude methods currently are
cropping rotating distorting all that
kind of stuff but you can imagine much
more complicated
generative processes that start
hallucinating different cats in order
for you to understand deeply of what it
means
for something to look like a cat right
what is the prototype of the archetype
of the cat yeah the archetype i mean
that's a very difficult process for
computer vision
to
you know to go from what are the pixels
that are usually associated with the cat
to like
what is a cat in the visual space in the
three-dimensional visual space that is
projected on an image on a
two-dimensional image
what is a cat
those are like fundamentally
philosophical questions that we humans
don't know the answer to
like linguistically but when we look at
a picture of a cat and a dog
we can usually tell pretty damn well
what's the difference and i don't know
what what that is because you can't
reduce that to pointy ears or non-pointy
ears
furry or not furries yeah about the eyes
it's been a long-standing issue in
cognitive science cognitive neuroscience
too
it's how how does the brain create
an archetype how does it create schemas
that are have general applicability
um but yet still obtain specificity
that's a very difficult
challenge we can do it we do it it's
yeah rather bloody amazing it seems like
part of the toolbox is this controlled
hallucination which is dreams
well it's a relaxing of the rigid
constraints you know i often think of
dreaming as
you know it's from an information
processing standpoint
you know the prison guards are away and
the prisoners are running a mark in a
delightful way and part of the reason is
because when you go into dream sleep the
rational part of your brain called the
prefrontal cortex which is the part it's
like the ceo of the brain it's very good
at making high level rational top-down
decisions and controlled actions
that part of the brain is shut down
during rem sleep but then emotional
centers memory centers visual centers
motoric centers
all of those centers actually become
more active in fact some of them are
more active
than when we're awake
in the dream state that's fascinating so
your brain from a neural architecture
perspective is radically different
its network feature is
not the same as wakefulness and i think
this is an immensely beneficial thing
that we have at least two different
rational and irrational conscious states
that we do information processing in the
rational the vertical the page one of
the google search is wakefulness
the more irrational illogical
hyperassociative google page 20 is the
rem sleep both i think are critical both
are necessary that's fascinating and
again fascinating to see how that could
be integrated in the machines to to help
them learn better
and to uh
to reason better
and in some ways we also know it from a
chemical perspective too when you go
into dream sleep
it is a neurochemical cocktail like no
other that we see in the at the rest of
the 24-hour state
there is a chemical called noradrenaline
or norepinephrine in the brain
and you know of its cystic chemical in
the body called adrenaline
but upstairs in the brain noradrenaline
is very good at creating a very hyper
focused attentive
narrow
it's sort of
very
convergent way of thinking
to a point sharp
focus that's the only thing the
spotlight of consciousness is very
narrow that's noradrenaline
when you
remove noradrenaline then you go from a
high snr a high signal to noise ratio
where it's just you and i in this moment
i don't even know what's going on
elsewhere i am with you
nor adrenaline is present
but
when you go into rem sleep it is the
only time during the 24-hour period
where your brain is devoid of any
noradrenaline it is completely shut off
and so the signal-to-noise ratio is very
different it's almost as though we're
injecting a greater amount of noise
into the neural architecture of the
brain during dream sleep as if it's
chemically brute forced into this
relaxed associative memory processing
state and then from an anatomical
perspective just as i described the
prefrontal cortex goes down
and other regions light up
so it is a state that seems to be very
i mean if you were to show me a brain
scan
of rem sleep and and tell me that it's
not rem sleep just say look based on the
pattern of this brain activity what
would you say is going on in this
person's mind i would say well they're
probably not rational they're probably
not having logical thought because their
prefrontal cortex is down they're
probably feeling very emotional because
their amygdala is is active which is an
emotional center of the brain they're
definitely going to be thinking visually
because the back of the brain is lit up
the visual cortex it's probably going to
be filled with past experience
and autobiographical memories because
their
their memory centers are lighting up and
there's probably going to be movement
because their motor cortex is very
active
that to me sounds very much like a dream
and that's exactly what we see in brain
scanners when we put people inside of
them
you